the pogo masterpiece ha can you jump a
bit no I just need to go forward a
little bit what that did not help me at
all in fact I've gone backwards from I
want to do a little bit more like it
that's not gonna work
I see the landmine back there but I have
a funny feeling that that's cheating hi
how about no do the opposite of that how
about I count it one it gave it to me so
I'm the best I'm a ninja ow
you've pinned my head into my butthole
ow I'm not exactly a very stealthy ninja
I wouldn't even set these off oh it's a
party everybody forget what the hell I
was talking about before I just want to
take a relaxing break here now that my
entire spine has been ejected from my
body and is just used as a an airline
pillow cushion for my neck this time I
didn't say nothing I won look I'm I'm
their [ __ ] not go backwards
tonight it's [ __ ] god damn it I got
my head stuck in my ass cliff Jim hello
oh sorry oh hi why is everybody on this
cliff
so I saved you you're welcome sir we're
gonna be pulled up to safety and you can
thank my broken pelvis and impaled peen
or hi little girl
are you in trouble well let me just let
me just bicycle kick for a little bit I
want to work my core strength up never
mind I guess the workouts over well good
for those balls bottle run number one
this is the first bottle run that has
ever been made and I shall be victory
well [ __ ] pushing forward on that it
catapults you well I made it and my bike
- I'm not missing anything else not that
I remember
I don't have anything else important
when I started this
fine it's like impossible to get Oh
the mayhem mechanics remember to swing
alert second invasion wait oh god how do
i oh oh there we go oh jeez my pinwheel
oh god Oh click here to win oh god I
didn't need to make this monument of
destruction I didn't need to sit on the
blood throne I could have just clicked
why did I do that it's word flight
simulator oh yeah I won't stab you
oh he looks like you lost kick this is
spirit oh yeah hey can you give that
back buddy
I kind of need it to kill Jesus oh I
didn't even need to stab you I didn't
stab you at all you stab yourself you'll
sail yeah yeah I'm gonna headbutt and
kick you at the same time I'm gonna
scissor your head in between mine hey my
foot in my face and it's gone strode ow
well that leaves me a little defenseless
oh [ __ ] guys already dad it leave him
alone Oh Oh God
his blood has become sentient oh look
out old man look out he's crazy it's
literally the butt stabber literally the
bud stabber there you go ok and then no
ground aah
that helps ok ok and then save my stuff
ultimate hail Lord Gabe n I'm sure
that's gonna be a good one but there's a
big button that says do not click there
so we'll go to clicker
ultimate how the hell our game goodbye
world
where's my Steam sale victim to cliff oh
oh it's similar but not the sow well
I'll just rest in this tree for a little
bit get my bearings before I once again
throw myself from the precipice half
else gives me sorry missed me dick why
is this solid missed again looks like
once more I am the winner of some weird
bizarre cliff diving contest aren't you
glad I just saved you from that horrible
fall well never mind here comes the
horrible fall let's hope you interrupted
the miracle my legs were moving oh god
they still are why why why is they still
are this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
want to see more happy wheels right now
check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video bye
[Music]